so welcome back everybody it's my great
pleasure today to be talking about two
sharp or software effort in general and
this announcement that we had a while
back and that last week officially we
went open-source so all of our software
and the qdk is now available online on
github in its entirety we've heard
plenty before about applications and
what you could potentially want to do
with quantum computing so by now we
hopefully have some ideas and some
inspiration on the problems we might
want to tackle at this point but the
question is how do we get there these
are all huge challenging problems we all
like to save the world but in the end
usually that turns out not to be quite
as easy and the way we think about
quantum algorithms and we teach about
quantum and quantum algorithms today is
very important for how people will think
about them in 10 years or 20 years and
what we built this future on essentially
sometimes they're very nice examples
like Grover Ford for example that is
somewhat little and this 2d plane you
can draw some diagrams have some
graphics but then when it comes down to
actually explaining what it is that the
algorithm actually is supposed to do and
how it works that usually looks
something like that in detail in a
classroom at a whiteboard with some
formulas and a lot more detail that has
that is on the slide obviously but if
you're looking back at this nice virtual
representation of this algorithm and if
you forget for a moment all the
nitty-gritty details we might want to
take a step back and fundamentally think
about what it is we want to do and we
want to achieve to come up with new
ideas with new ways of looking at a
problem and approaching a problem before
we go into the technical detail exactly
on which sign goes where so if you would
explain exactly what people are supposed
to do based on this speed
on this diagram what you would probably
come up is something like saying well
you got to get yourself a uniform super
position to make sure your state has
some overlap with where you actually
want to go and then we can do two kinds
of reflections for a suitable number of
time that will effectively rotate or
state in space such that we rotate
towards where we want to go after you've
done that a sufficient number of time
you can measure and get hopefully a
state that is collapsed to what you
wanted to know I've written down for
example here in Q sharp how this might
look like and the nice thing is really
that we still have pretty much these
lines yes it's maybe not entire
sentences but still fundamentally we can
express they're supposed to be a uniform
superposition you're supposed to somehow
mark where you want to go your target
state you flag your target state and
usually that's the difficulty with this
amplitude amplification kind of things
you somehow need to mark it and that
needs to be efficient and then you can
just reflect against the plane do that a
couple of times and you're done so
looking back at fundamentals for example
teleportation what we often see our
diagrams like this one here so okay this
is nice this is official it's a pretty
picture it's nice to have in a paper
because sometimes if you do a lot of
theory it's kind of hard to sell your
papers without some pictures so in that
sense sometimes we want to have them but
scaling up can be a little bit tricky so
if you have too much to draw basically
if you have a lot of nesting a lot of
branching that here is in this
classically controlled gates actually
then it might come in a little more
handy to actually have a code or
pseudocode representation of it because
at the very least we've got if
statements that somehow make it a little
bit cleaner and especially if you have
more than just one X or one sec aid in
there but what's more than that it's not
just about that it's also if you look at
this agent to see not what is it we want
to do it's not telling me a whole lot of
what the intent is there so instead of
calling it agency not which means a lot
to everybody who has already worked in
the field but not necessarily to the
people getting
into it we could instead write well we
want to entangle two qubits and then we
sort of want to transfer and manipulate
a kind of entanglement to do something
useful with it so hopefully we hope to
abstract out somewhat that line of
thinking that thought to make it
approachable and workable for people who
have context in chemistry have context
and and biology or anything else
material sciences where these things may
come in handy but not necessarily the
entire foundation of having had a degree
in quantum information theory because
when's the last time that you saw
something like that I hope some of you
code and I hope none of you had to deal
with that or maybe you did and your work
on hardware but basically I'd rather
write a plus B because it's just so much
faster so this is a basically that we
want to achieve with the software that
we are building and stepping back one
step we've got to ask yourself what is
it we want to achieve fundamentally when
designing a quantum programming language
when designing a software platform how
what expectations do we have and on one
hand as I mentioned in a sense that's
abstraction that's talking about what we
want to do rather than how strong the
pulse sequence has to be to achieve that
for a particular platform for a
particular hardware so in a sense we
want to be able to talk about what we
care about and what we're working on
rather having to have expertise in
anything from superconducting materials
up to number theory and complexity
theory on the other hand they're always
going to be the people who download the
algorithms and most likely hopefully
they're going to know a whole lot more
about this algorithms than most other
people
who would use them as part of a as
building as part of building on it and
developing new ways of utilizing that
specific sub routines so we want
encapsulation and what's important
usually when you have abstraction and
there come a capsulation you end up
paying some
over half price usually because you've
got all your nice transformations and
then once you start plugging them
together you could probably eliminate
some of it and now we've got the choice
you can write an application start to
finish given all the input values for
every problem you want to solve for
every application you actually want to
run on quantum hardware that's doable if
you have one or two applications given
you know where we are currently that's
currently certainly doable if you ever
actually had a paper where you wanted to
get a numerical data or something like
that you probably ran into your problem
where you wrote a lot of scripts that do
exactly that that somehow tests a bunch
of input parameters test a bunch of ways
of plugging stuff together and so on so
there are two ways we could go one is
the responsibility is up to the
developer to actually make this
connection make sure that there's no
performance over had to be paid from
abstracting things out which requires a
lot of work or we can provide in the
language the means to annotate the
information to provide the information
that is necessary to automate that
process as much as possible and we chose
to do the latter end it's a very cute
shop it's very young a very new language
we certainly there's the first steps
done and there's certainly a very long
way to go but this is where we want to
go of course especially given the early
stage of the field given how Hardware
works given that devices are probably
going to be more or less reliable for
the next couple of years we do want to
know that our code is correct we've
heard before it's a large problem to
debug quantum hardware and you don't
just have to debug quantum hardware
there's the hardware that's unreliable
there's all great ins that are usually
probabilistic rather than deterministic
so there's a margin of error there as
well we can estimate kind of give
guarantees with pounds using triangle
inequality usually it's the easiest way
to go the problem is these are and
usually not very tight so to make it
actually usable to actually speed up a
lot probably we might want to just try
out and heuristic we figure out what is
kind of the right step size
example if you have a trucker ization or
something like that but that requires
some confidence in that what you're
doing is actually what you want to do
you know in the correctness of your
implementation so in a sense our first
priority is prior is optimization of
course making it efficient to run on
quantum hardware but once that satisfied
as much as we can track about whether
you intended to do what's going to be
executed that's also something we want
to do furthermore we want to have some
idea about resources about how many
qubits do you need about how long is it
gonna take probably once you have access
to quantum hardware you're not just
going to hit enter and hope for the best
and see if it runs within the time that
you know your qubits are alive but at
least it should have some idea on
whether that's doable and again
versatility is very important such that
we can figure out kind of incrementally
improve algorithms improve Hardware
improve the ways we formulate an entire
program and how we handle optimization
of that program
and lastly execution as I mentioned
efficiency we want to leverage the
hardware that we have given that we are
very much fighting for every qubit
fighting for everything we can do we
want to optimize what we have and
reliability especially in terms of code
so this all brings me to a couple of
questions that I think about a lot and
for me it's all about information
essentially once when you write the
program what you have is somebody with
an idea how to solve a problem in their
head where you want to get is to somehow
translate that knowledge into something
that Hardware understands specifically
to do so what we need to have is a way
to convey that information and that
information can be conveyed in various
ways and usually it's used and broken
down and once you've used it you know
once you've inland something you lost
the information about where to read
operation started and ended so there's
usually a trade-off once you've used it
it's probably no longer there you can
use it for one thing or for the other so
it's very important to think about these
things and these things specifically may
be very different than in conventional
compiler construction for example
because there are decades of research
going into what we currently do to run a
program on your laptop
whether that's exactly the right way to
go about doing it on quantum hardware
that's entirely an open question and the
reality is until we actually run a
couple of things until we have
benchmarks and test suits and some
research that goes into that we won't
know so we're very early here we make a
first attempt our goal is to make a good
first attempt with Q sharp to do that to
do exactly that it's certainly something
that hopefully will grow but also will
evolve and morph because some of the
things we think today are important may
not be very important in the long run
and other things hopefully pop up
fundamentally what we want to do is we
want to reason about an algorithm and
that's really what it's all about so I'm
not going to go into more details about
what exactly is in the language if there
are any questions I'm happy to answer
them I'm happy to go into more specific
on language features on capabilities and
trade-offs that we have done so far and
where we might want to go but I think
the important idea is what I said before
to get the pretty picture in a sense we
want to somehow combine some processing
usually some classical processing heavy
classical computation is something that
generates heat which is one of the main
bottlenecks currently for data centers
and anything like that so realistically
there's always going to be a classical
part to it for heavy processing that's
not gonna run on your 4k or even lower
where your qubits live so there needs to
be some coordination between the two
probably compiling it with things with Q
sharp we're not competing against high
performance classical libraries for
machine learning for example we provide
arbitrary classical control flow because
it's very important to reason about the
program structure and center
but we're not going to compete with
numpy or anything like that that's in a
sense not the right expectation because
it wouldn't run at the same level and
then we of course also want to actually
execute it and as mentioned something
needs to coordinate between what is
processed where so that's pretty much
what makes your software stack and for
today to figure out if that even is
remotely reasonable we want some tools
to actually assess whether we are
getting somewhere we were wrong to get
and we've got plenty of that Q sharp is
one of course we also got an arsenal of
tap tools that are there to make it
easier for people to get into it to
learn it to work with it
we've got simulation framework set up
because most people probably don't have
a quantum computer in their basement or
access to one so for our daily work
basis it's probably helpful to have some
simulation capabilities for us
specifically that means not just the
full quantum state simulation but also
resource counts and anything you could
do possibly to sort of get as good an
understanding as you can about your
Guren before you actually go and try to
do something on real Hardware in
libraries naturally so as far as the dev
tool goes we do provide a couple of
things a couple of integration we're
going to hear more about that also after
that talk there's two extensions that we
provide but that's mainly you know what
we provide we have a language server
anything that supports language server
protocol can use the cue can use that
server to communicate with the cue shrub
compiler so if your favorite editor is
Emacs or sublime or anything like that
we are now open source feel free to
contribute for the simulation as
mentioned we got a couple of simulators
there
we're working we're certainly always
listening to the ask what the community
wants and needs and will be helpful to
have and we've got libraries like
chemistry arithmetic libraries and
some set of course material and
exercises and taqaddas that Maria is
going to talk more about a little bit
later that she's all written this is one
of our newest edition estupido notebooks
a few the extensions are easily obtained
by just downloading your favorite editor
vs code in this example go to extensions
and download them and the how Q sharp
looks like is that it works more or less
in its a processor model where you have
to sharp code that is eventually
supposed to be executed more or less
than a quantum processor router the
actual Q sharp runtime and a driver that
actually calls into that code the driver
right here is C sharp but it could be
anything in principle we run that course
or you just need to somehow be able to
call in to.net core and what the nice
thing about that set up is for example
for the trace simulator you can actually
configure a little bit what it's
supposed to be watching also some
durations arbitrary a set for particular
intrinsic operations or gates that give
you a better idea on how you're all
Gurdon might perform how certain
adaptions might impact that to be
somewhat helpful what you can get also
on one hand here's exactly number of
gates as you see there but also we allow
you if you run on a four-state simulator
to actually dump the state to look at
them the kids
I know it's helpful for debugging though
we're really on from a cue sharp
perspective we're focused on the
operations on the transformations you
want to do because what a quantum state
is in a sense is not relevant to what
you want to do so our focus there really
is the transformation itself and how
they relate to each other more
importantly and with that we can do some
pretty powerful and cool things as we've
seen one or two slides before and some
as we've heard about the chemistry
examples for example here
with of course all the usual tools for
plotting the whole thing comes with nice
documentation hopefully we're always
working on improving that what we have
in our documentation is on one hand
getting started kind of quickly setting
up your environment some documentation
on what the libraries are on what the
language are a detailed API
documentation for everything in our
libraries that is generated and that
should cover the most basic things what
is also helpful sometimes to watch for
as we have it that block coding contests
and new language features or releases or
something like that for those more
invested in actual development and
possibly also these tools that might be
a good place to look and there's a
complete set of link that is probably
get to take a snapshot off as I've
mentioned the open source repos the list
there has gotten a little bit longer
lately and I'm happy to show that right
life
okay
so here's one of our repositories that
just went online last week which is the
compiler kind of the core piece to
actually run quantum algorithms do
development and so on you don't need to
look at the source code of the compiler
and the extensions and so on this is
really if you're curious about what we
do and at some point it's also going to
get you know a little bit more clear
looking through the repository where
we're headed and where we want to go if
you find issues and things that you
think should work and don't here's a
good place to file them we've got a
runtime repository that contains in
particular also all of our simulators it
contains also a piece that generates
c-sharp
because you need to execute on something
so Q sharp itself right now is taking
text and building an abstract notion of
that text we're on the process of kind
of writing the actual compilation piece
breaking it down that hopefully should
happen over the next year or so but for
the purpose of executing it anywhere
right now we're pretty much generating
c-sharp based on these high level data
structures and leveraging the
capabilities of the c-sharp compiler
which are a lot more relevant and more
practical for actually running on
classical hardware and in simulators
than anything that we might want to do
for quantum s and there's also a third
new repository which is the IQ sharp
repository which is the piece that makes
the chip return integration possible and
also kind of having Python as a driver
for example easy to have so let's let me
show you a little bit how it looks like
if you're actually working with an ID
this right now is in Visual Studio but
that's purely because I happen to like
it you can use vs code or anything like
that the nice thing with Visual Studio
is you've got the unit testing framework
and you've got the help that the editor
can provide via our extensions this is
one of our cutters for example
to show you a little bit just you know
how working an idea might look like on
one hand it's helpful that you see
everything that is declared in this file
you can jump to it go to it right here
as mentioned the cards the idea is that
their set of tasks you're supposed to
solve and when you initially run all the
tests are supposed to fail and your job
is to make them pass waiting dream and
there's a nice set of instructions that
come with it that explain what it is
you're supposed to do and why we want to
do what we want to do and for example
here create an entangled pair it tells
us to actually that we get two qubits in
a zero state and we're supposed to
create a bell state a particular one we
can do that right now
and as you see as I'm typing I do get
live feedback whether what I'm typing
actually makes sense and also in
particular for example here it will
actually show me the next parameter it
will show the description of what that
next parameter actually is supposed to
be that's all built based on
documentation comments in the code and
our libraries are fairly well documented
such that if you're hovering on things
like scene up for example here you do
get a description of what that gate is
actually doing so it can have Q to you
here run the test again and we should
see that indeed that particular test
hopefully should now pass and I've
already filled in a third one so having
solved that one actually makes the other
one pass as well we've got all the
features for example you can see well
peak where this declaration is we see
here there's for example a type
declaration here it's got two items
named bit 1 and B 2 to represent the
message you want to transmit this here
is the super-dense coding kata so the
goal is to transmit two classical bits
by physically by using the resource of
entanglement and physically sending one
cue
so there are a couple of nice features
on that the compiled provides for
example if you're forget and open direct
if you see here now finding this thing
it's pretty easy it's a chest to you
exactly where to look for it you can
click on it it's actually going to
insert as a open directive again as you
know from other languages like C sharp
and F rope where similar functionalities
are also available obviously they're
always working on improving that we've
got renamed for example that makes it
fairly easy and convenient to work with
it's just writing two lines of code it's
fairly straightforward writing a couple
of hundred lines of code which hopefully
people working on quantum algorithms
will at some point is easier to have
some support here we have this whole
thing also in Jupiter notebook format
and Maria the next speaker is going to
talk about it some more I'm just going
to show you a little bit you can
actually clone for example a caddis
repository you get an index and the list
of all things here that are available
and as I mentioned you're gonna see more
about that a bit later on as I mentioned
things are also available in vs code
here we see the example to actually just
create a Bell State and then see what
the state is we can run it with top net
sorry
just dotnet run we'll do what we want to
do and what we get here is an output
that is now a little bit less readable
with what the amplitudes are for
particular cubits for qubit one rather
for state 1 state 2 state 3 state 0
and in case you were wondering a little
bit how this whole thing works for
example with tracer where we have
branching based on measurement results
the way it's currently implemented is
that when you write for example
teleportation and you have a branching
here what the tracer does is actually
follow one particular execution path and
the path it follows is going to be
probabilistic depending on what
probabilities have been annotated for a
particular branch so what we did here
for example is to say ok here are an
assertion regarding what the state of
the qubit should be we can have similar
assertions before branchings that
basically say the probability I know
from based on my knowledge of the
algorithm is supposed to be that and it
will just probabilistically follow
whichever path according to their
probability if you don't said anything I
believe it's a 50-50 chance and there
ways obviously to force each each path
and branching again there everything is
open sourced you're certainly nice
things one could do with that and build
on that and have a more clever way to
get an entire understanding of the tree
for your program and we're always
working on improving our tools so before
I go into full demonstration here I
think it's easier if I just open up the
round for questions for anything you
want to see any any other software
aspects you would like to look at and I
think that probably makes more sense
no questions so then I hope for plenty
of contributions and people using it or
at the very least bug reports that's
always a good sign that people are
actually using the software perfect then
I think we're all excited to hear more
about course material and how to
actually use these tools
[Applause]